trois hectares de terrain pour 750 m² de
pépinière seul gilles simon peut s'y
retrouver
tout est dans sa tête originaire dousson
sur loire il a installé sa pépinière à
quelques kilomètres de là à polisy gien
c'était il ya plus de 40 ans chez lui
quatorze mille variétés
alors ça c'est un chêne qui vient du 4g
ce temps une jeune dans tata qui montera
à peu près 10 mètres et qui fait des
fleurs les feuilles énorme énorme des le
très gros blanc de groote relative la
plus très lentement très lentement sa
spécialité les espèces rares les plantes
qu'on trouve uniquement dans une
certaines collections botaniques comme
les anglais sont très fort là dessus
beaucoup plus fort connu et qu'on trouve
uniquement dans les jardins repères
c'est original c'est magnifique je
puisse connaître tout cas donc on est
très beau déjà tout petit sa passion
c'était les plantes et à défaut de
voyager lui même j'estime ont fait venir
des graines du monde entier il se
fournit auprès des arboretum en france
ou encore chez des collectionneurs en
grande bretagne car aujourd'hui les
échanges sont plus difficiles beaucoup
de pays ont bloqué l'entrée l'entrée des
graines sur l'europe peut dire que voir
des graines des états unis il faut
porter par la pologne la lettonie
il faut arriver en europe oui le manège
qu'il faut faire maintenant pour la
dgrad malgré la retraite gilles simon
continue à s'occuper de son jardin
plus de dix heures par jour difficile de
s'arrêter quand on a la main aussi verte